there are people who make a mistake and
admit they made a mistake and they move
as quickly as possible in the direction
of fixing the mistake that they made
there are other people who make a
mistake and they double down either
because their ego won't allow them to
admit defeat or because they genuinely
can't change their mind and consider
that they might have actually done
something wrong Donald Trump is in the
latter camp he doesn't admit to making
mistakes he usually does double down
even on the worst mistakes that he's
made and right now one of the biggest
mistakes that Donald Trump has made in
his still early presidency is the trade
war that he has started and Donald Trump
is doubling down and he's doubling down
so hard on this that he started to make
completely wild and wacky claims with no
connection to reality whatsoever the
reality of the tariffs that Donald Trump
has placed on American allies around the
world is that they're going to hurt
American businesses and also American
workers that's the reality trade Wars
are not good or easy to win
despite Donald Trump saying that they're
good and easy to win the tariffs are
gonna make American products more
expensive around the world that's going
to hurt American businesses it'll hurt
workers the tariffs are going to lead to
retaliatory tariffs from our allies that
will make their products more expensive
for us that's also bad for Americans who
aren't necessarily swimming in extra
money with which to purchase foreign
goods and Donald Trump most recently
this is so whacked out has suggested
that the tariffs might be so good for
the United States that the revenue
created by the tariffs could conceivably
make the federal income tax unnecessary
and this is so silly
that it's hard to know whether it even
warrants a response or if it's just an
example of how disconnected this man is
from reality when a play video for you
Trump is saying that the tariffs could
be so good that it could be like when
McKinley was President of the United
States in the late 19th century what the
hell does Donald Trump know about
William McKinley and that the United
States didn't even need income taxes at
the time because just
tariffs can be so good it is completely
perverted logic but it's sort of what
Donald Trump seems to be applying to
this situation take a look 30 percent
tariffs or so tariffs can be a very
positive thing you know the old days
when we had tariffs we didn't have
income tax when people wanted to come in
you look at the days of McKinley and
some others when people wanted to come
in they had to pay a price when they
want to come in and raid our treasury
fair to pay a price we didn't have
income tax you didn't need income tax we
didn't have debt so we're doing this I
will say in every instance every country
any country that you can mention has
been extremely nice so what he's saying
is in previous times when we had tariffs
and no income taxes things worked really
well so therefore his tariffs now are a
good thing now it's just so you have the
data federal spending is a portion of
the total economy is ten times higher
now than it was during the McKinley era
that Donald Trump references so as a
comparison this is totally meaningless
this is the type of math that leads to
bankrupt casinos and it is not that
shocking that the guy who thinks trade
wars are good and easy to win and knows
nothing about taxes and has no clue how
to run a government might think that
maybe if you do really well with the
tariffs you wouldn't even really need
the federal income tax
yeah when McKinley was president we
didn't have Social Security we didn't
have Medicare our military wasn't what
it is now yeah it wasn't what 15
government departments and countless
more agencies well care sustainable
careful because that's the logic they'll
used to say well we got to get rid of
all that stuff
we got a shrink Social Security and
we've got to get rid of a bunch of those
government departments right so you got
to be careful with that logic military
can stay big though both military can
double absolutely we need it much bigger
sometimes I listen to this stuff and I
think back to my high school economics
class there were students in my high
school econ class who seemed to have a
better grasp of these big economic
issues and fundamentals than Donald
Trump has and I want to mention the
McKinley thing the fact that Trump
mentioned President William McKinley who
was president starting in 1890
seven this isn't something Trump is an
expert on if Trump is mentioning William
McKinley it's because somebody told him
mention William McKinley I don't think
anybody at this point believes that
Donald Trump is a casual historian who
knows a lot about President William
McKinley such that he could make this
comparison in this this casual way I
would point to either Stephen Miller or
I don't even know a coke brother or
someone who has Trump seer on this stuff
it's like when Steven Bannon got him
interested in Andrew Jackson exactly man
the comparisons started and didn't
really end this is absolutely ludicrous
it is a gong show a comedy of errors
harebrained idea after harebrained idea
I don't know what analogy or phraseology
you want you want to apply to it but we
are in a period where total ignorance
and saying whatever comes to mind or
whatever somebody said in your ear five
minutes before a camera got turned on is
being accepted as some kind of
truth-telling tough-guy patriotic gospel
I I don't even know what other word to
apply to it and it is stunningly
disturbing Donald Trump gave another one
of these rambling incoherent speeches
that were so bizarre that you couldn't
tell whether the teleprompter switched
to Mandarin in the middle of the speech
or maybe Trump was having some kind of
medical incident because no sensible
explanation came to mind other than
total incompetence and we know that
Donald Trump recognized that the public
relations around caging little kids was
bad who could have guessed right and so
in an attempt to fight back against what
Trump saw his bad publicity about his
immigration policy he put together
people whose family members were
allegedly clip killed by quote criminal
illegal aliens here's a little bit of
Donald Trump's bizarre rambling
incoherent speech we're gathered today
to hear directly from the American
victims of illegal immigration you know
you hear the other side you'd never hear
this side you don't know what's going on
these are the American citizens
permanently separated from their loved
ones the word permanently being the word
that you have to think about permanently
they're not separated for a day or two
days they are permanently separated
because they were killed by criminal
illegal aliens these are the families
the media ignores they don't talk about
them now you might say hey David that's
not deceptive there are illegal
immigrants who killed people and these
are the families of their victims so
what's wrong with that shouldn't we know
if there are criminal illegal aliens and
I would say to you sure that's a problem
we should focus on all people in the US
who commit violent crimes whether
they're here legally or not the problem
is that when you have to stop and think
about why Donald Trump did this rally
and gave the speech the insanity of it
surfaces the bad PR is around the
separation of children from their
families the separation of children from
parents who aren't even breaking laws in
some cases because they're coming to the
border and seeking asylum not entering
the United States illegally and Donald
Trump is pushing back against critics
who say caging kids is bad by saying
some illegal immigrants killed people
he's holding the rally to make people
afraid of dangerous immigrants and then
of course the biggest insanity insanity
of this all is that undocumented
immigrants commit less crime than
native-born Americans we have data from
the libertarian Cato Institute about
criminality in Texas and what you will
see is that native-born Texans commit
crimes including all crimes in general
but also specifically homicide and
larceny at higher rates than both
documented and undocumented immigrants
so if you're holding a rally merely to
warn people about who's dangerous by
crime rate you have to be way more
afraid of in this case native-born
Texans than undocumented people in Texas
one more set of data for you at the
state level higher rates of undocumented
immigrants correlate to a lower crime
rate from 1990 to 2014 the data is clear
we did an entire long-form piece about
this on the truth about illegal
immigration you can find out more about
this issue by checking out that video
last thing on this the economic side
I hate to break it to anybody who's
finding comforts and solace in the
immigrants are bad because they're
taking our jobs thing but if you lost
your job to an immigrant
shouldn't you be blaming the business
owner who took advantage of the
immigrant at your expense to lower their
costs and increase their profits the
people hiring the immigrants are the
ones that are laughing all the way to
the bank because you're mad at the
immigrants instead of them this is
free-market capitalism or at least it's
what I call it Pat is free where we want
it to be free capitalism and I know
we've gone over this before but how can
the immigrants be both lazy welfare
recipients vagabonds who don't want to
work and taking so many jobs that real
Americans like you can no longer fight
find one explain that to me and you'll
never see Republicans blame the business
owners who hire these illegal immigrants
now don't give them a tax cut every once
in a while they will say and we should
also enforce the law when it comes to
businesses that hire undocumented
immigrants but they don't really have
the political will to do it absolutely
immoral what is happening here you can
discuss this with us on our subreddit at
david pakman.com slash re d di t yet
another day and yet another example of a
federal law violation by Donald Trump
targeting a specific company on Twitter
I'm starting to feel as though the
English language is being pushed to its
limits to adequately explain the crisis
level stuff that's going on right now
with this administration Trump is now
threatening Harley Davidson with being
quote taxed like never before if they
move overseas which they're being pushed
to do because of Donald Trump's own
tariffs so I want to break this down
step by step for you Donald Trump
started a trade war he put tariffs on
Chinese European Canadian goods as
predicted the countries that were
tariffed
by Donald Trump decided that they were
going to put in place retaliatory
tariffs this is how trade Wars work
completely unsurprising and as a result
we've had some American companies
harley-davidson being one example
announced that they're going to move
some element of their business over
in Harley Davidsons case they are going
to try to get around tariffs that would
increase the cost of each motorcycle by
2200 s by moving production of their
European market motorcycles out of the
United States so Harley moving that
production overseas is a direct response
to the repercussions of Donald Trump's
trade war when harley-davidson announced
hey this is what we're going to have to
do Donald Trump goes on Twitter and he
threatens Harley with punitive taxation
tweeting yesterday quote a
harley-davidson should never be built in
another country never their employees
and customers are already very angry at
them if they move watch it'll be the
beginning of the end they surrendered
they quit the hora will be gone and they
will be taxed like never before
understand what's happening here Trump
first hurts Harley Davidson by starting
a trade war Harley reacts to save their
revenue and Trump says I will hurt you
even more if you try to get out from
under the destructive effect of the
trade war that I started Trump forced
them to make a business decision and now
he's going to punish them for making
that business decision to try to save
their profits and of course it won't
matter to Trump supporters Trump
supporters will say you know it's
Obama's fault because he was weak on
trade or congressional Democrats
obstructed fixing trade deals so Trump
had to do this and Trump's just gonna
have to be tough in order to make this
right which of course makes no sense
since the whole point of fixing trade
was to be good for American businesses
not so terrible for American businesses
that they say wow we have to save
ourselves and offshore even more jobs
which is exactly what's going on I was
thinking about how the EU targeting
harley-davidson is actually kind of
clever because Harley is seen as this
kind of Heartland American icon and by
putting harley-davidson in a position to
have to make this decision
harley is in a position where
conservatives will have to decide do we
denounce Harley because we're supposed
to see Harley as this American icon but
at the same time if we say we support
what harley-davidson is doing we're kind
of criticizing Donald Trump because we
were admitting that this is what they
have to do because of Trump's trade war
and the real lesson is that trade war a
policy by Trump is half haphazard and
it's also a losers policy Trump can't
win it right we can go into the esoteric
economic details or we can just
understand that in broad strokes Trump
can't win the trade war businesses are
going to suffer middle class Americans
are going to suffer and I don't take
pleasure in this every time we talk
about this Pat people email in and they
say David you anti-american freak you're
pleased by what's going on no first of
all if you say that you must acknowledge
that there are bad things going on
that's number one so why don't you just
criticize the policy as opposed to
criticizing me I don't take pleasure in
400 points wings in the Dow I don't take
pleasure in the exploding of oil prices
that we're now seeing and I certainly
don't take pleasure in this economic
instability I'm just not gonna sugarcoat
it for you I've got to tell you the
truth I thought we were supposed to be
sick and tired of all the winning at
this point in your presidency we're not
really thinking that we're not seeing it
we're not seeing it with Harley Davidson
and I also want to give you another
example of Jack Daniels whiskey that is
really going to suffer under Trump's
trade war another day another racist
faux pas by a Republican that you're
just not allowed to call out because if
you notice their racism you were playing
the race card if you believe that I feel
sorry for you annex Trump advisor went
on Fox News and called the black
Democrat quote out of his cotton-picking
mind of course the term cotton-picking
refers to one in the south of the u.s.
in the late 1700s the early 1800s black
slaves picked cotton Lou Dobbs years ago
once had one of these weird incidents if
Lou Dobbs is before your time I know we
have some younger viewers on the show he
used to be sort of a prominent CNN
anchor who hosted a quote money show and
I think he's now on Fox Business if that
show hasn't been cancelled here's Lou
Dobbs
almost accidentally using the term ten
years ago we're living with the issue of
race we've got to be able to talk about
it and I can guarantee you this not a
single one of these cotton yeah I think
just ridiculous politicians should be
the moderator on the issue of race right
when talking about how great things are
racially he calls politicians referring
in fact to condi rice who happens to be
black in that segment cotton pickin just
cringe so cut to this weekend here is
former Trump advisor David bossy quote
debating or engaging in dialogue with a
black Democratic strategist named Joel
Payne and out-and-out says
cotton-picking take a look here final
point you said that about David David
Michael Michael Hayden posted a picture
of Auschwitz Michael Hayden yeah that
scream you're out of your cotton-picking
mind we're gonna leave it right this is
ridiculous ed Henry panicking saying hey
hey he said you out of your mind
very quickly got out of control
eventually David bossy did apologize for
his choice of words tweeting quote
during a heated segment on Fox & Friends
today I should have chosen my words more
carefully and never used the offensive
phrase that I did I apologize - Joel
Payne Fox News and it's viewer so the
apology is fine most trumpets don't
apologize so even getting an apology is
something but the reality is that the
problem isn't just that he said it it's
that as soon as he's in disagreement
with a black guy
he immediately either consciously or
subconsciously goes to cotton-picking
and the question is why and even wackier
is that the the conversation was about
civility in politics and whether it was
appropriate for Michael Hayden to tweet
a picture of Auschwitz as an analogy to
what's going on with the child
internment camps and as you see on the
screen behind me their own headline for
the thing was the left's racist rants
continued as the guy from the right
calls the black guy on the left out of
his cotton-picking mind could this have
been
at some kind of avant-garde performance
art is it possible that David bossy was
on ambien a time and the ambien maybe
got him to say this wacky thing there
are people defending him online
like imagine this being the hill that
you die on people online are defending
david bossy saying that he's a child of
the 70s and any child of the 70s has
cotton-picking as part of their lexicon
with no racial connotations and it just
comes out reflexively and if that's the
argument my question is why is it that
the incidents in media tend to be white
Republicans using the term
cotton-picking when talking to or about
black people is it another one of those
coincidences yeah and why didn't you
mention that in the apology I it's weird
because whenever I get angry I don't
become a racist I think it could have
been the ambien I do I don't
all of a sudden incorrectly use that
term yeah that's that's the other thing
that always comes up which is well you
apologize for the use but it's clearly
what you automatically go to when you
become frustrated with someone in this
case when you become frustrated with a
black guy who quite frankly was making
him look pretty stupid on Fox News we
have even more fallout from this
harebrained ill-thought-out trade war I
don't personally drink Jack Daniels
whiskey but many people do and in Europe
many people also like Jack Daniels
whiskey and those European customers are
going to have to pay ten percent more
for Jack Daniels whiskey as a direct
result of Donald Trump's trade war the
European Union has placed a number of
retaliatory tariffs against American
products as a result of this trade war
put in place by Donald Trump we've
talked about how harley-davidson is
moving some production out of the United
States an American whiskey manufacturer
Jack Daniels is going to have to bump up
prices in Europe by 10% and what's going
on is that over the next few months the
distributor's that European beverage
spirit distributors have are going to
start going away they're going to have
to start buying more to replenish those
supplies and they are going to have to
do that at a ten percent higher cost
that 10% price increase is obviously
going to be passed along to the European
Zoomers of the whiskey and what you're
going to see is some European consumers
saying well I don't want to pay ten
percent more for Jack Daniels I will go
with a different whiskey maybe Japanese
Japanese whiskey increasingly popular
maybe some other no Jameson generous
whiskey yeah oh that's another
possibility and if you think well who
cares it's not a big deal Jack Daniels
doesn't really sell that much in Europe
wrong actually 25 percent of Jack
Daniels revenue comes from European
sales so think about it we were told
that Donald Trump's mere presence in the
White House never mind his economic
policy was just gonna be masterfully
wonderful it's gonna be an incredible
amount of winning the American business
class is going to win the American
middle class is going to win but instead
we're seeing the opposite we're seeing
that companies are being hurt and
workers are being hurt by the economic
policy if you can even call it that I
call it fumbling around in the dark but
I want to remind you about what Trump
himself said trade wars are good and
trade wars are easy to win doesn't seem
to be working out and unfortunately
because of Donald Trump's ego he can't
back out of it now Trump is so dug into
this bogus policy that if anything he's
going to double down on the policy
before he backs out of it and he's now
calling out the companies that he's
hurting as we talked about calling out
Harley Davidson on Twitter Trump's
making threats as a result of his own
destructive policy and the best way that
I can describe it is that this is a weak
man's strong man and then in addition to
the damage that actual price increases
are going to do the movement to boycott
American products is growing we talked
about the Canadian effort to avoid
American products because of this
hostility and trade war starting from
Donald Trump there is a European
movement to choose non American products
when there is an option and this is the
bed that Donald Trump is making he's
going to have to sleep in it and unless
we don't hold him accountable
he might actually face some
repercussions that's my concern he's
making the bed make the guy sleep in it
by voting in November and voting in 2020
that's the only way I think there is a
chance he'll back down remember he did
for the child separation you know family
separation for immigrants yes
Republicans and the public at large went
against him he decided to backtrack a
little bit if corporate interests get
involved here if the Koch brothers get
involved maybe you'll see a change of
heart yes and no because he did make a
public declaration and sign an order
that he was gonna take care of the child
internment problem but it was just the
Vegas of executive orders Vegas of
executive orders and I don't actually
know that he's really fixed the problem
in fact it appears as though now there
are even missing kids that are supposed
to be in government custody I don't
expect any backtracking I would expect
doubling down before I see backtracking
from Trump you can discuss this with us
on our subreddit at david pakman.com
slash our IDI di t we are going to take
a very very quick break newly shortened
commercial breaks and then we'll be back
back in 1974 43% of Americans said that
President Richard Nixon should be
impeached this was from a Harris Paul
done in March of 1974 right now 42% of
Americans believe that Donald Trump
should be impeached according to a new
SSRS poll and four people saying that
lots of people always want the president
impeached that's sort of true but not to
this degree for example at the height of
the Bill Clinton scandal only 29% of
Americans wanted Clinton impeached and
as you might know Nixon eventually
resigned in August of 1974 just five
months after that 43 percent number was
hit but there's a key difference between
when Nixon resigned and what is going on
with Donald Trump which is that Nixon
ultimately resigned not so much because
43 percent of Americans wanted him
impeached but because Republicans his
own party had lost faith in him when we
look at what's going on today
Republicans mostly still love Trump so I
don't believe that we can expect that to
end the exact same way there's another
key difference right now which is that
Richard Nixon didn't have Fox News they
didn't have the 24/7 propaganda machine
of right-wing media supporting the Nixon
administration and even if at any given
time
one percent or so of the united states
population is watching any particular
show on fox news fox news does have a
sort of right-wing agenda setting
ability and that is a catalyst for
really effective talking points in
defense of trump that end up being used
by people who don't even necessarily get
them from fox news one other difference
is that Donald Trump is still polling
approval wise in the high 30s which is
sort of the same point as saying
Republicans still support the guy and
then one other difference today compared
to 1974 with Nixon is that the electoral
map is way different today than it was
during the 1970s and so as a result I've
said this before this isn't new
impeachment shouldn't be a policy item
for Democrats going into the November
elections the midterms and mostly it
isn't because you can't run on
impeaching the president since it
depends on so many things and it's not
policy especially when the replacement
is Mike Pence if Democrats run on we
will impeach the president when we get
elected and take over the House and
Senate in 2018 in practical terms you're
running on making Mike Pence President
of the United States it also simply
can't happen if Democrats don't take
over the House and Senate especially
when even that can be sort of a losing
battle unless Republicans change their
mind Nixon would have held on and on and
on if Republicans had stayed with them
you can't win a fight against people
without moral and ethical standards
meaning that this is merely a practical
matter Republicans stay with Trump
you're not going to see impeachment or
resignations so Democrats need a real
platform for 2018 and we're about four
months away and it needs to be developed
right now because the one target needs
to be for Democrats to take over the
House and Senate in November if
Democrats can take over the House and
Senate you potentially get net
neutrality back which is a massive meta
issue for the propaganda war you neuter
the Trump agenda because if you take
over the House and Senate you relegate
Donald Trump to the executive orders
that he denounced under Barack Obama and
given Trump's authoritarian
índices if it starts to look really bad
for Republicans in the House and Senate
as we get closer to November I would
start to wonder are we going to see
authoritarian type moves from Trump and
by that I mean preemptively arguing that
the election is invalid some kind of
terrorist attack to fire up his base
firing Robert Muller to create chaos and
maybe try to swing things back towards
Republicans in an act of desperation I
don't know and I normally say no way to
the mere possibility of these things
happening but we've gotten pretty far
off course during the last two years of
Trump so I would be very concerned
number one if Democrats don't get a real
platform together for the midterms I I
would almost completely write off the
possibility of taking over the House and
Senate I hope that doesn't happen but if
it starts to look like Democrats might
actually have some success there what
does the Trump administration and
Trump's lackeys what do they do to try
to retain control beyond January of 2019
when the new House and Senate would be
sworn in I want to start today talking
about this little thing called the
Constitution Donald Trump his team his
staffers his supporters they've been
carrying on about the rule of law and
the Constitution and how under their
watch we are going to have the rule of
law in this country we're going to have
law and order and if I say to you the
rule of law in the United States the
definition of it is general but also
precise in a way the rule of law is
quote the restriction of the arbitrary
exercise of power by subordinating it to
well defined and established laws the
arbitrary exercise of power keep that in
mind in our country just because law
enforcement says you did something or
thinks that you did something before a
particular punishment is carried out
before the allegations are put into sort
of a final decision phase there is a
process of the law and when
comes to undocumented immigration if law
enforcement thinks someone came to the
country illegally you still have a legal
process which confirms the circumstances
and looks at the facts and only when
that has been refereed by the justice
system do you move forward with for
example the punishment of deportation
I'm ignoring by the way that there are
two justice systems in the u.s. one for
the rich one for the poor but for this
story that's not actually the main focus
Donald Trump said yesterday that he
wants people who come into the United
States illegally deported immediately
without any judicial process Donald
Trump tweeted quote we cannot allow all
of these people to invade our country
when somebody comes in we must
immediately with no judges or court
cases bring them back from where they
came our system but weird weird grammar
but we understand what he's saying our
system is a mockery to good immigration
policy and law and order he actually
mentions law and order in a tweet
calling for the total elimination of the
rule of law and this is what we would
call unconstitutional this would violate
due process and there actually is some
debate among constitutional scholars a
group to which Donald Trump doesn't
belong in case you weren't sure about
that constitutional scholars do debate
the extent or degree to which all
aspects of the Constitution apply to
non-citizens to people who are here
illegally or to people who are residents
but not citizens but there is no
question that cancelling trials for
suspected undocumented immigrants is
completely unconstitutional the Supreme
Court has already decided that anybody
in the United States whether you're here
legally or illegally you are entitled to
due process of law it goes to the second
half of section one of the Fourteenth
Amendment and it's very clear that it
applies to all persons there are parts
of the Constitution and the Bill of
Rights that make a distinction about the
rights of citizens versus the rights of
all persons but there is no question
whatsoever that there is a
right to due process for people who are
in the United States regardless of how
they got here so there are people online
now let's take a step back
supposedly trumpets and Trump and the
right are advocates of the Constitution
they are defenders of the Constitution
they say we like Trump because he will
enforce law and order and the rule of
law
so the constitutional right should be up
in arms and absolutely furious about
this idea from Donald Trump because it's
a direct violation of their stated value
of defending the Constitution but I
checked the forums online I went to the
normal enclaves of bottom-feeding
pond-scum online and they're loving this
idea from Donald Trump here are some
examples that I came across quote if
they're illegal we don't need to waste
time and money with courts just get them
out another comment correct as usual
about Trump's idea of just kicking
people out with no due process and quote
he is correct illegals have zero rights
here get them out the Constitution
doesn't work this way and I am I have a
call-out I'm formally putting the call
out right now patent make a note of this
please if there are any so-called
constitutional conservatives who are
ready to stand up and say this cannot be
allowed to happen I am going to put
party aside and say this is an attack on
the basic fundamental tenets upon which
our country is based let me know because
I want to hear from those people
actually is surprising in a way because
conservatives always argue that due
process point on the topic of guns yeah
like sometimes will be a push to take
people who are on the no-fly list or the
terrorist watchlist
and make it harder them for access to
guns guns and even maybe take the guns
away conservatives say that would
violate their due process that's exactly
right because being put on a list is not
a judicial adjudication of any kind
right you appear on a list and all of a
sudden you lose rights that are granted
to you either by statute or court
precedent or the Constitution and Bill
of Rights that would violate due process
they say well then this absolutely would
and I actually am curious even going
beyond I think
the ship has sailed with most so-called
constitutional conservatives who support
Trump they're going to come up with some
reason to either just ignore this or
defend it but what about government
agencies are there government agencies
that would actually be doing what it is
Trump is suggesting here that are going
to be willing to stand up and say we're
not going to do it because whatever our
political disagreements are about
immigration policy or quotas or country
of origin or whatever even if you think
we want people from Norway and we don't
want people from Guatemala like Trump
has suggested you can still say but
we've got to do what the Constitution
says I hope that there will be
government agencies that do that I'm
sure that the heads of those agencies
will very quickly find themselves fired
by Donald Trump however it'll come down
to the individuals at their respective
agencies I think just like with the
child detention fiasco there will be
some whistleblowers some people who take
a stand and say we're not gonna go
through with this others will go along
with it I think you're probably right
I think you're probably right and this
is a this is a direct attack on the
Constitution and I wish that we could
get beyond partisanship whether it was
Obama was accused of doing this stuff of
course he wasn't actually doing it Trump
really is right there were no FEMA camps
under Obama there really are child
internment camps under Trump President
Obama wasn't trying to suspend the rule
of law Donald Trump is actually saying
get rid of due process altogether and
just start kicking people out on the
say-so of I guess Border Patrol agents I
don't even know who this is a crisis and
we actually have multiple crises to talk
to you about today